I had a different name brand smartwatch,
but I kept running it through my dryer and, like,
dropping it and breaking it,
so I needed a new one.
And this one from the TikTok shop is pretty much the exact same thing.
Only difference is it's a lot lighter.
You can tell why the price differences there.
It's just a lot lighter. It feels much lighter on your wrist.
I don't think the bands switch out exactly the same.
It's like a different way to switch out the bands.
But there's an app that you download,
and it's exactly like the other app that comes with your phone
for your other watch. But I don't know,
it's just so expensive to have that much money on my wrist.
But I like having the heart monitor.
I like being able to check my messages,
my emails, my everything from my watch.
And, like,
it's a camera shutter. It's, like, everything.
So if you're like me and too clumsy to own really expensive shit,
this from the TikTok shop is very worth it.